-My first guest
is one of my favorites.
She is an Oscar-, Emmy-,
and Tony-winning actress.
She stars in "F9," which hits
theaters Friday, June 25th.
Here is Helen Mirren!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, my gosh! Yes!
Oh, my gosh!
You are the absolute --
You are the greatest ever!
Oh, my God!
That is the greatest.
Oh my goodness! I love you!
Helen!
Helen --
-I'm in my favorite place
in the world.
-Oh, my God!
You are the greatest.
I love that you're in a --
You might be
the first guest ever to be
in a bathtub on
"The Tonight Show" as a guest.
-Well, you know, that's
the brilliant thing about Zoom.
I was thinking, you know,
"Why not be in the place
that you love to
sit and chat to people?"
I love having a chat
to my husband
while I'm sitting in the bath.
So why not do it
to the whole of America?
-Yeah, that's very smart.
Why not?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's why you're the best.
I love --
-I'm running out of
bubbles, though.
That's the problem.
You know, you were chatting
away, and I was waiting
and bubbles were going down.
-Oh, I'll make the
interview very fast then, yeah.
-Alright, fast, please.
Fast and furious, yes.
-Fast and furious.
Oh, see? We already segued in.
Brilliant mind.
I do want to ask you
some questions, though.
I love that you're in a bathtub.
It's so fun.
I follow you
on the social medias
and I see that you're
very in tune with nature.
Wherever you live,
there's lots of creatures
and animals and squirrels and --
Well, squirrels, yeah.
-Chipmunks, golden mantles,
blue jays, coyotes,
and, of course, bears.
-Now, I have a clip of you,
a black bear --
Helen Mirren
confronting a black bear.
Take a look at this.
-Come. Come on here. No.
[ Knock on window ]
Go on.
-That's not going to stop it.
-Go on!
-You better watch out.
-No, he's fine.
Go on, go on! Go on, bear!
Go on!
Naughty bear! Naughty bear!
Naughty bear!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Naughty bear!
Naughty bear!"
Is yelling "naughty bear" --
is that exactly how
you get rid of a black bear?
-Well, it worked, didn't it?
And I've seen that bear since,
and every time --
I think it's a she.
I don't know if it is or not.
Every time I see her,
I go, "Naughty bear!
Naughty bear!
Go on! Off you go!"
And off it goes.
-I think you should make
"Naughty Bear"
into a children's book.
I would --
-"Naughty Bear," yes.
-"Naughty Bear."
-Kids love that.
-Yeah, why not?
-Kids absolutely
love that video.
-Yeah.
-Show it to your kids.
They love it,
'cause I think they get
told off so often.
They're told that
they're naughty
and they should
go to bed or something.
So they really recognize it.
-Can you -- Tell me about
your show that you're doing,
speaking of nature.
It's called "When Nature Calls
with Helen Mirren."
I think it's really funny.
Great title.
But explain the premise, 'cause
that's what I really love.
-It's a lovely idea.
It's all the off-cuts from these
great nature shows, you know,
when they do these
incredible nature shows,
especially the BBC.
They have hours of film
that they can't use
in the actual program.
But it's great footage.
I mean, incredible footage.
So we've taken that footage and
we've sort of, you know,
given the animals voices,
you know,
and made them sort of
understandable in their world.
It's a way of putting ourselves
within the animal world
and just showing that
we're all --
We all share the same planet.
It's very funny, too.
-I think it's
really funny, yeah.
I love the --
I love that premise.
You know, I was researching you
for this interview.
Of course,
we've done many interviews.
And I realized that
you're very close to an EGOT.
You have an Emmy.
You have an Oscar.
You're a Tony winner.
And I think that next is --
I mean, do you want to
announce it tonight?
Are you dropping an album?
[ Laughter ]
-I wish.
I have a terrible disadvantage
where a Grammy is concerned,
which is,
I absolutely can't sing.
I mean, I really, really,
really can't sing.
So, you know,
it's a terrible disadvantage
for an effort to get a Grammy.
Maybe I could do
a spoken-word album,
but that's as close as I'm ever
going to get to a Grammy.
-But then what is this?
'Cause I found this photo
of you on the Internet.
-Oh, that's from
a long time ago.
Yes, that was a
theater show I was doing,
and it was called
"Teeth 'n' Smiles."
And it was about --
It was sort of based on
Janis Joplin, in a way.
So I'm kind of
trying desperately to channel
the great Janis Joplin there.
But I did sing onstage,
but, really, I shouted onstage,
sort of vaguely in tune,
but maybe not at all.
But it was a great experience.
-Was it, like,
a rock 'n' roll audience?
-It was pretty rock 'n' roll.
It was the first time
rock 'n' rollers
came to the theater, actually.
It's the first time
they'd ever done a play.
And -- But I proved
the fact that
I'm so not rock 'n' roll
by nature.
You know, I'm a sort of
good theater girl by nature,
rather than a
mad rock 'n' roller.
Because one night,
Keith Moon sort of
appeared out of the blue.
Well, actually, out of a rubbish
bin that he'd fallen into
in the alleyway
outside my dressing room.
And I heard this huge kerfuffle,
you know, at the stage door,
which was down below
my dressing room.
Coming up the stairs
outside my dressing room,
and then bang, bang, bang
on the door.
And I opened my door.
And it was just before
my last entrance in the play.
And, here, it was
Keith Moon standing there.
He said, "'Ello, Helen."
I said, "Gosh, Keith, you know,
what an honor to meet you.
How fabulous."
He said,
"I'm coming onstage with you.
It's supposed to be fantastic.
I'm coming onstage with you."
And to my absolute discredit,
my rock 'n' roll discredit,
I sort of got very English and,
"Oh, no, no, Keith.
You know, I don't think
that's a good idea."
He was completely blasted,
incidentally.
He was completely out of it.
So I did say no,
and it was a terrible mistake,
because, I mean, how --
It wouldn't have mattered
how chaotic it had been.
It would have been just such
a fabulous experience
to be onstage with Keith Moon.
-You would have been
a member of The Who, yeah.
-Absolutely, yeah.
-You know what?
You're already a rock star.
You don't need it.
We love you, bud.
I want to talk to you
about "F9,"
the latest in the
"Fast and Furious" franchise.
More with Helen Mirren
in a bathtub.